I'm not sure if you heard about this,
but the 2016 election was completely
been at as trump and hillary were
actually the only part of it,
as there were other characters from
Bernie and Jeb to Marco and Ted.
The election also caused the implosion
of the mainstream media and set us on a
path that has hashtag Maga racing
towards hashtag resistance with the rest
of us caught right in the middle,
Ohio governor John Casick was one of the
more moderate voices in a campaign
season that we're short on moderation.
As a fiscally conservative,
socially liberal Republican.
I see casick as someone who has some of
the right ideas,
but who's timing just wasn't right for
the madness of 2016 cases.
Team reached out to us a couple days ago
and we have him in studio today,
totally unscripted and unedited with no
advanced knowledge of the topics or
questions.
I think this is exactly the way we need
to be hearing from our politicians and I
hope that this interview helps dls in on
these conversations in the near future.
Joining me today is the author of the
new book,
two pads,
America divided or united,
a former Republican presidential
candidate,
and the current governor of the great
state of Ohio,
Governor John Casick.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Gets a really good television voice.
How is that?
Well,
we were just sitting here.
You were kind of normal and they were
like,
dude,
you know,
it was like Ted Baxter.
Very good.
Ah,
Ted Baxter.
I like the reference that did not go
over me.
Well,
you know,
I liked.
Of course everybody else watching,
they don't know who he is,
but that's okay.
They could google it.
Some of my millennial people won't get
it,
but they should google who ted Baxter
is,
that would,
that would be good for them.
So,
uh,
first one I wanted to start with you.
I'm incredibly excited you're here.
And it's interesting because your people
reached out to us about four days ago.
They said the governor would like to
come in and then we quickly set this up.
Nobody said,
oh,
we have to talk about this or we can't
talk about this.
You sat down here about two minutes ago
and you said whatever you want to do is
fine,
and I feel like that is partly what's
lost in politics right now,
that we're going to just do this.
It's not just lost in politics.
I see it lost in a lot of things.
You know,
I met with this big car company and like
they had these guys come in to see me
and it was like they were totally
scripted and uh,
you know,
so I think,
life is having fun.
Life is,
you know,
being able to be real.
And the reason why we wanted to do this
is I actually kind of saw part of one of
your shows and this media is a really
amazing.
A lot of people don't get it and I'm
starting to get it and I have some
people around me who say this is really
a way to keep your voice out there.
You know,
that's what I want to be able to have a
constructive positive voice to help our
country.
And this is another avenue that I'm glad
no one else has found it yet.
In my profession,
so we can be a first mover,
which I,
I really,
I really like and I liked the fact that
we can actually have a conversation
longer than just a couple soundbites.
Do you ever worry that because we've
lost the ability to do this,
that the soundbite world is what's
causing so many of the problems?
Well,
that was what happened in the campaign.
It was all,
you know,
we didn't do it but these other
campaigns and I had advice from some
people who had run before,
make sure you get your little thing out
there so you can blow up the television
morning news and you know,
and it's like tricks,
you know,
that's not a good thing.
And I look,
people I saw,
I saw a thing on a sign yesterday had
said,
email me,
please,
we have to talk.
Yeah,
I think the.
Look I,
I didn't have a smartphone for a long
time.
I have,
I've had an ipad and I got to the very
beginning,
but I didn't have a smartphone and
people would laugh at me,
but I didn't need this stuff during the
day,
you know,
I didn't need to have basketball scores
or look at the weather 25 times or some
kind of headline in the news,
uh,
or my emails because I have people that
can tell me if there's a crisis.
They tell me,
I go,
okay,
well let's see what it is.
Um,
but I got my smartphone and now the best
thing about it is that I can text,
but I find that I text,
you know,
what it does is it creates a laziness,
right?
You don't have to go through a
conversation now,
don't you think?
Look,
you have a,
you have a show here where people talk.
What do you think about it?
Don't you think this is a problem?
I mean,
I think that resetting our ability to
talk and actually think and sit across
from somebody and make some eye contact
and really try to understand what they
think.
I think that is almost the most
important thing that we'd given up and
these last couple of years,
it was the tradeoff between all these
devices and the immediate,
uh,
response.
So what do we do about this?
I mean,
I,
I honestly think that you come in here
right now and your people being brave
enough to say,
yeah,
it's not like I have people,
you know,
these are people that work around,
kind of support me and help me.
They're friends and,
but this whole,
you know,
sort of funny.
We were,
you go on these shows on regular
television which I think are really
important and you get,
you know,
2 million people to see you.
But if you were like hanging out with
Logan,
Paul got 16 million subscribers.
It's like,
and you know,
the funny thing about it is that people
can't see it really now,
but that's not really true because I
think probably you're in demand now and
you can go out and make talks and people
show up to see you.
Um,
but it's kind of an invisible world to
those who were kind of hooked on
television,
right?
You under stand.
What I mean by that?
I do.
So how do we,
how do we bridge that?
I don't know,
but I gave you,
you know,
what's I think it's called what's news?
It was really fantastic and there were a
couple of million views and,
and I liked it.
Um,
you just have to keep doing it.
It's part of why I wanted to be here.
I mean,
look,
I pull up here,
you got a studio in your garage.
Um,
it's,
it's cool.
It's neat and you don't,
you don't have to go very far.
My Commute's about 10 minutes,
but the hard thing is got to be getting
compelling.
Guess that's got to be a hard thing to
do.
How do you go about doing that?
Well,
unfortunately a lot of people are coming
to this medium now and a lot of the
guests that you asked me right before we
started all these books here,
I mean most of the,
I think virtually every single one
except the Carl Sagan book.
Are there any of them that are
interesting,
boring,
and I don't know.
There's some great books there by,
by many of my guests from Steven pinker
and Sam Harris and Scott Adams,
and plenty of ice.
You have one here on John Adams,
so that's good.
We did a president's week a couple weeks
ago.
John Adams.
So you're getting,
you're getting good.
People of color were getting,
was it,
you know what,
a lot of times when I am with press,
I'm actually curious about them and they
don't like it when I'm asking them
stuff.
Okay.
It must've,
it must've been hard in the beginning,
right?
It's hard to build anything.
I mean,
you know,
that.
But I.
One of the things that I consistently
tell my audience is it's cool that a lot
of the beliefs that I have,
I,
you know,
I fall a little more within classical
liberalism and libertarianism,
a lot of the beliefs about doing things
for yourself and I've built this
business with the same ideas that I try
to talk about here.
Uh,
some of which I think we're going to get
to.
And it's kind of a beautiful thing if I
keep.
Not,
not if you keep going.
All right.
Let me ask you a couple of questions as
long as you're here.
So I thought just first I thought we
them just a little bit about growing up.
What kind of family you grew up in.
I feel like people never do that in
politics anymore.
We go to immediately mocks me because I
say my father was a mailman and so the
people write that in there,
like cynical and all that.
But I grew up in a towel and it was
over.
I mean,
I don't think I ever met a Republican.
Not In my town.
My uncle Harry was a republican.
They say we didn't listen much to him.
He's a great guy,
but you know,
it was blue collar and you know,
was sort of the,
some of these people you would define is
Kinda the trump people you know,
who felt they had been left behind.
So,
you know,
as a result of that,
I guess that's why I'm a populist,
but a positive populace,
not a negative populist positive that we
can do what we can together we can,
we can rise.
And,
um,
that's a great place to come from
because you really have a sense,
you have a sense of people,
you know,
and it's not just the upper crust,
uh,
we respected the upper crust.
I can remember saying to my father one
time,
Daddy,
what about the rich?
He said,
well,
we don't hate the rich.
We want to be the rich,
you know.
And so it was great God fearing
conservative Democrat,
good values.
Faith was a,
was a part of my early childhood,
which I normally drifted away from when
I went to college,
you know,
so like Augustine,
he says,
you know,
I need to,
I know I need to be committed to God,
but just not right now.
I have a couple of parties to go to.
So,
you know,
we all drifted away and I've not
drifted.
I've come roaring back into that.
But common sense,
right?
A freewheeling,
sometimes it puts people off a little
bit the way I am because I'm pretty
direct.
And,
but the other thing is I was telling
somebody the other day that,
you know,
I don't want people to be confused about
my positions on anything.
And so if somebody says,
well,
I think it's blue,
and I might say,
well no,
I think it's red.
And they,
most people would expect me to say,
okay,
well I'll consider that.
And I'm like,
no,
I just don't think that.
And I think to some degree people don't
get it.
So it takes a little bit of time for
people to come to understand me.
Yeah.
All right,
well that's what we're going to do here
for now.
So you mentioned a couple of interesting
things there.
So you didn't grow up in a Republican
family and you just used the phrase
conservative Democrat.
So one of the things I talk a lot about
here is that it seems to me before we
get into your party that the
conservative Democrat or the blue dog,
democrat or sort of the moderate
Democrat,
a lot of them were buddies of mine in
Congress,
great friends.
Do they really exist anymore?
I think this is,
I think this young man in Pennsylvania
is blue dog Democrat from what I can see
now.
He got elected at 33,
I think I was 30.
So he's kind of an old timer.
Yeah.
But no,
I think that um,
I think in both parties it's really hard
if you're a republican,
you got a fear of the right and if
you're a Democrat you fear the left and
it just pulls everybody apart.
You know that though.
But,
but you've managed to kind of work
through something that's sort of
centrist,
right?
Somehow.
Well,
I don't know what that means.
You know,
one guy once told me,
the only thing that goes down the middle
of a road are yellow lines and dead
skunks.
Okay.
And,
um,
I'm not a,
but I'm a common sense person.
Well,
I guess I look,
I look at an issue and say,
okay,
what do we do about it?
And we look at a problem.
How do we fix the problem?
But I'm not really going to have an
ideological.
I'm forced.
It's kept pulling me back.
But the same time being a conservative,
I want to see what the solutions are
without having to bring bureaucracy or
government in.
And I'll tell you why that is.
It's because government inherently a is
so subject to political considerations
that people have a hard time make
calling a spade a spade.
It's like,
no,
I got all these pressures and I don't
like that.
And so when you go to government you can
get trapped,
but you get trapped with big business to
big business.
You know,
you try to like,
I need this prescription,
you know,
and somebody out here is telling me,
oh no,
no,
it costs too much,
you know,
big things like that all have always
bothered me,
you know,
big institutions,
whether it's government.
Uh,
uh,
I grew up,
my dad was in a union,
I always like unions,
but you know,
the problem with the unions is when the
union boss not representing the worker,
and I'm so big,
institutions don't throw me,
where am I?
Kind of unpredictable because you kind
of labeled yourself a little bit ago.
You said,
well I'm this and that.
If you asked me what I am,
I'll say I'm a conservative,
but then you will say,
well,
but why do you think this or that?
And uh,
because I don't think we need to be
stuck right there.
Being stuck in life is really
depressing.
All right,
so tell me about what does being a
conservative basically mean to you then
if they.
Again,
government is government as a last
resort,
not as a first resort,
but,
but I also don't think it's like no
government,
you know,
how do you decide where that you use
your judgment and you list,
you have good people around and you
think about things and we're trying to
price something right now in our state.
Somebody wants access to stuff in our
state.
Okay.
It would,
it's a good thing.
It's a good thing what they want,
but I don't know what the price of the
value of it is.
Okay.
So I can't just look at what governments
have done to determine the value because
I don't have.
No,
I don't have a whole lot of.
I don't invest a lot in that.
Uh,
I want to go out and talk to a variety
of people in business to say,
what do you think this is worth?
Okay.
And um,
so how do I do that?
People that come in and they talk and
they argue for certain things,
but at the end I have to decide.
So I just use good judgment as I can.
Do you have a certain leeway when it
comes to sort of thinking for yourself
as a governor that may be the senators
and the congressmen can't have because
they have to all,
not that you don't have to come together
and work with people.
You have to have to do it from,
with people outside of their state with
massively competing interests and things
like that.
I was offering budgets against
Republican presidents.
I mean,
just do your job.
why would you want to be.
Why would you want to have a television
show where you don't make it real?
Why would I want to be in politics no
matter where I am and not make it real?
I mean,
what would I be there for?
It's really stupid,
right?
I mean,
there's a lot of people there I don't
want to be,
I don't want to be casting aspersions or
judging them only for me.
Why would you do that?
I mean,
so we had a decision on Medicaid
expansion,
right?
In Ohio,
you know that,
you know,
that Medicaid expansion,
of course,
right?
So I just really.
Jan Brewer and Arizona did it,
which really was kind of shocking to me,
but I was really the first big state,
big Republican governor who expand it.
Was it hard?
Was a piece of cake.
If I'm going to get money that's not
going to put me in a straight jacket
from the federal government.
If I can use that money to heal,
to help heal or help help to help the
mentally ill so they're not sleeping
under a bridge or living in a jail.
Or if I can help people who have drug
addiction to get treatment and get off
of it,
if I can have a lower uninsurance rate,
why wouldn't I do that?
And because people are going to yell at
me and fight with,
so what?
Who Cares?
I mean I care.
I don't want them to not,
I don't want them to be anxious.
In fact,
in my state of the state address I was,
I made a talk that really had almost
nothing to do with policy.
It'll had all to do with basically
philosophy and the meaning of life.
They say it was the only state of the
state speech delivered by a governor in
the history of the world where the name
Cammo was discussed.
But I,
I,
um,
and I didn't mention that because I
don't want to jab anybody in the eye,
but the decision to do that,
to help people,
it's just,
it's such an easy decision.
Do you find you have a little bit of
extra freedom right now because you
can't run for reelection and Ohio now
there's a lot of talk at 2020,
which I want to end the interview.
Oh look,
I mean,
I'm probably so,
but I've always been very independent.
You know,
I was a military reformer.
I was offering my own budgets against
President Bush.
I took on corporate welfare reform,
couldn't find a Democrat with a search
light.
And the Republicans ran the other way.
Um,
no,
I,
I've always pretty well felt that,
you know,
you gotta do what you have to do and uh,
and my more free now and maybe a little
bit but,
but I,
I,
nothing would change.
I mean,
I don't know,
what is it I would reverse,
I wouldn't say,
well,
we're not going to do this medicaid
thing now if it got us into point where
we were fiscally at risk,
I would have to stop it.
I've told everybody that,
but no,
I don't really think so.
But I am having probably more fun now.
You know,
having a lot of fun.
I mean I can tell that I've been having
fun.
You know,
I ran for reelection and I,
and I never even used the word Obama
running for reelection.
Never talked about it.
I just talked about our record and it
was fun and it was positive.
Look,
here's the thing,
and we all need to know this.
We all need to be healers in one way or
another.
We need to heal our family and our
friends and strangers.
I'm not that great a guy.
Okay.
But I know that that makes sense and I
know that it's right.
So it's just a cool thing to think about
and that's why politics is so boring to
me because it's all these,
all these calculations and all this
crap.
Why don't we just do a job?
Let's think about how to pull to pull
the country together.
Let's make sure that we can help people
to be lifted.
Let's not tear somebody down.
Elizabeth Warren wants to tear down all
these rich people.
I don't know why,
or Bernie or whatever.
I used to work with Bernie.
It's,
you don't need to tear people down.
We need to just build people up and,
and put them together.
Yeah.
Did you ever get into any of those
philosophical discussions with Bernie?
Because the class war thing I see,
I see as extremely dangerous.
No,
I don't have a conversation with Bernie
had been burning and I,
we're in a house together.
He was,
you know,
really kind of in another orbit.
We all thought he was.
And yet,
you know,
the country's kind of moved towards him.
And I think a lot of young people are,
you know,
the one thing that is concerning to me
and I have great faith in the
millennials and the gen x,
but I'm not sure they understand the
consequences of losing a representative
democracy.
There seems to be with some of them,
some appeal towards an authoritarian
figure.
Have you.
Am I right on that?
I think you have to tell me I haven't
studied it,
but I've got that sense that's not good
or that you know,
maybe socialism will work.
Look and free enterprise system.
Michael Novak,
the great philosopher,
theologian said that a free market
system that is not underlaid with a set
of values is bankrupt.
So you have to have values.
You can't just be in it to make money.
There has to be something else there.
Where do you think those values come
from?
Oh,
I think they.
I think that they.
The easy thing to say politically easy
thing to say as they come from mom and
dad and I say to people,
well,
where do you think mom and dad got it
from?
Well,
they got it from their parents.
Where do I think these virtues come
from?
Look,
if you're a humanist,
I respect you.
Okay?
Uh,
you wake up every day trying to figure
out how to make the world a little
better place.
I like that.
Okay.
But for me,
the winds of change,
the fads can knock me off my path.
So,
uh,
I need something deeper than that.
So I look to theologians and I believe
that we are,
we are a unique form of life,
greater than all other life on the
earth,
and I think that life has given to us by
our creator.
And I think our creator has a character
that we can learn about and that's not
only held by a Christian but also a Jew
and also a Muslim.
We have the same kind of view of
creation and our purpose and within
those values are things like mercy and
justice and compassion and forgiveness.
And,
you know,
um,
I don't know if you played golf that we
see we have to have mulligans in life
because we know and I,
and the danger of talking about these
things is that people want to say,
oh,
well,
you don't have great values.
I caught you.
Yeah,
of course.
I'm just a slob on a bus trying to make
it through life,
you know,
but I kind of know what I need to do.
So I think that these values,
they flow from,
from our creator.
And I think too much in religion today,
which has turned off a lot of young
people.
Uh,
I'm actually mentoring a young man in
faith,
but it's not about all this judgment we
hear.
It's about hope.
It's about human connectedness.
And that's appealing to people.
And it's what I think is true about
faith and virtue.
It's not confining,
it's enlarging,
it doesn't make you smaller.
It makes you bigger.
And today in religion we see a lot of
forces that are counter to that.
And I don't like it.
Yeah.
Well,
it's interesting to me because my,
my audience knows that Thomas Jefferson,
who was my favorite,
favorite founder and I go to the
Jefferson memorial often in dc and I try
to read those big plaques and to me
they're as relevant now as they were,
you know,
200 some odd years ago where he talked
to,
you know,
they talk about a creator at the same
time they're talking about why church
and state have to be separate.
And I think that's really to the heart
of what you're saying.
Well,
I think first of all,
um,
we don't want the government being
involved in religion.
Uh,
we don't want that.
We want though in a free society.
Look,
freedom means we have to learn to self
govern and if every time we turn around,
this is a big thing about facebook now
they didn't self-govern right?
I mean we can pass all these rules,
but you know,
guys like you and me were met,
were born to figure out how to get
around the rules.
Okay?
Right.
I want to be free.
That's why we're both here,
but what I'm saying is that you can't,
if you're going to have freedom,
people have to have self restraint and
the less self restraint we have,
the more the government tries to impose
things and the more they impose things,
the less freedom we have.
So I don't want it.
I believe that,
that,
that our,
our faith system,
and again,
if you're a humanist,
that's cool with me,
that's fine with me because you're
trying to do good every day.
I just,
it can't work for me because I get to
knocked off kilter by the culture today
and the winds of change.
But with that system,
it,
it reinforces the sense of freedom.
So it's interesting.
You've referenced culture a couple times
and one of the things that seem pretty
obvious from an outside perspective of
the 2016 election was that trump
captured the culture,
good or bad.
He captured that.
He captured the Internet culture.
The reason that you're on.
And I was like 80,000
votes,
so we have to keep it in perspective and
trump is,
but he,
he's a negative populist.
I'm a positive populist.
The people that I grew up with,
when they're out at work or whatever,
my message is,
this is terrible,
but let's go fix it.
I think the negative populous messages
while you're out of work,
because that guy over there took it away
from you.
He took your stuff away and that creates
a bitterness and an anger and there's
also a sense that that can translate
into victim hood.
I'm a victim.
You ever like to be a victim?
My,
I do not want to be a big no,
but it's easy to be a victim.
Don't you think?
It's very easy.
It's particularly if you have other
people around that want to be a victim.
Now I'm not going to condemn them,
but it's easy to fall into that.
If somebody tells you you don't have
something because somebody else took it.
So what we need to do is,
if you were to go to say Youngstown,
Ohio,
they talk about that a lot in the
national news.
And I was a steel worker.
I worked in a coal mine in West Virginia
or whatever we have in Ohio working
with,
um,
with one of the tech companies.
We have a list of all the job openings.
Okay?
Now,
if you're a victim and I come to you and
I say you are a coal miner or your steel
worker and this would be hard for me to
listen.
I can show you this Internet stuff,
right?
And I can get you one of these jobs.
You don't have to become an expert,
but I can show you stuff.
If I'm a victim,
I may not want to do it,
but if I,
if I give that person a message,
hey,
look at these jobs.
It pays good money.
Your family will be healthier,
help will be healthier,
your children will be healthier,
you will have more self respect,
but you know,
it's tough where you are.
I under that.
That is the better message than,
well,
you're just a victim and we're going to
go and punish people.
Right?
That's done.
It doesn't work for the good for the
mental health of our society.
Yeah.
So I mean that's a great phrase right
there because we seem to be in a mental
health.
Came up with that.
That's pretty good.
Did you write that down?
We can go back and hey,
roll the tape back there.
They used to do that on television.
Roll it today.
Could say we're long past their tape.
There's no tape anymore.
It's all digital.
So,
but negative populate the electrons back
and.
No,
no.
So negative populism.
Do you see that train coming?
Because it seems to me that trump
grabbed it.
Istation.
He's not.
He didn't create this people for a long
time.
I felt that the rich get richer and the
poor get poorer.
People in my party have ignored that.
Uh,
maybe to some degree early on I did too.
I thought,
well,
what's that all about?
But it's true that you see these chasms
and those are dangerous because you
know,
we need to believe that all this wealth
and everything changes.
They say that the ocean always kind of
flips upside down.
And that's what we need to see in our
country that,
you know,
people in the bottom can get to the top
and we look and Bayzos guy selling books
out of his garage.
Look at you.
It's just a matter of time til you're a
billionaire,
you know,
you,
operating out of this girl.
He's delivering me a lot of stuff
everyday.
But you see what I'm saying?
I mean,
it is possible to rise in a free society
with a free enterprise.
And um,
do you think we stopped selling that
correctly?
Because as you don't think we talk about
it.
Yeah.
That young people now they starting to
think that socialism is
cool.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't get that.
I mean,
well,
because it sounds good,
you know,
like let's share.
I tell you a really interesting story.
My chief of staff,
there's that,
you know,
that show that you get on your phone at
9:00
eastern.
It's like they ask questions and you
answer the,
my kids have done it for awhile.
They don't do it anymore.
I don't know what,
what the show was called.
Um,
well anyway,
she and her kids,
daughters,
they listened to this every,
every night at 9:00
and they work together and so she said
one day to her kids,
why don't I,
I'll be on one phone and you got,
you'll be on your phone and,
and,
and joy,
you'll be on your phone and let's have a
competition.
They looked at her like she was crazy.
They're like,
why would we do that?
You know,
so,
you know,
when I,
I guess what I'm saying about that is
the idea of community and together is
good,
but we don't want that to erode the
basic sense that competition is good as
long as it's played fairly and everybody
has a chance to compete.
So really what you're talking about,
you're sort of talking about
individualism and how we can create
groups around that as opposed to
collectivism,
right?
Yeah.
What really the thrust of that,
write that down.
That's a good one individually rather
than collectivism.
But if you're a young person,
you go,
I don't know what's wrong with that and,
but look there my hope,
because they would rather take a job
that pays less if the job has meaning,
look at what they're doing in Parkland,
look at what these young people are
doing across this country and using
social media to,
to have a voice.
I mean it's,
it's really awesome.
it gets me really pumped up because the.
I think we need a new era of activism
and citizenship and by the way,
we're,
we fixate all the time on the leader.
Okay.
Did you see that movie on Churchill?
Darkest Hour?
I didn't see it yet.
I just saw the common law.
A lot of him in the crowd.
You and Gary Oldman.
I know.
I got to get out there.
It's on demand now.
I'll do it tonight.
I'm giving you my word.
Oh my word.
Yeah.
Anyway,
here's the thing.
Watching it tonight in that movie,
and this is made up stuff.
He gets on,
he gets,
goes down and gets on the subway and
he's talking to people and they're like,
you.
We're not given in,
and they,
they,
they embolden him,
set the fire in him.
I'm not telling you that,
uh,
that he wasn't a great leader because he
clearly he was,
but it was a bottom up and top down.
I mean,
when we think about the civil rights
movement,
I mean,
they didn't.
The great leaders,
Martin Luther King,
David,
good help politicians were afraid of
him,
including JFK.
Um,
they were all afraid of him.
And what happened,
it was,
it was from the street up,
a lot of social change,
uh,
the end of the Vietnam War.
How much longer would the generals have
said we were winning?
And by the way,
look at Afghanistan,
they keep saying,
oh,
we're victories just around the corner.
Terrible.
Um,
and so you have a situation here where
you can't just expect change in the
country because I have elected a good,
I have a new good coach,
so therefore I'm going to win a
basketball game.
It doesn't work that way.
It works both ways.
You a good leader,
but a great group of people that drive
that drive change.
How dangerous then is that cult of
personality that we've now made around
the president,
and I'm not just saying that trump here,
I mean even with Obama and plenty of the
other presidents that we think that
somehow the executive branch is going to
fail,
this one person is going to fix it.
You know,
there's a book that I don't know that
I'm like,
I don't know a lot of things here.
I'm giving you might be over here.
The book is not.
Here is a book that says this.
Um,
and I have never talked about this
before.
Like on television.
I was with a,
a,
a great preacher.
A got 6,000
people.
He's in the Silicon Valley.
He's very grace oriented and hopeful and
he's just,
he's a phd in psychology.
He's just got all this stuff,
all this talent.
And I was asking him,
I said,
I keep telling people it's bottom up,
not top down.
He said,
well John,
it's interesting because a man wrote a
book and the book says that when pieces
of our society start to erode,
let's think about it.
Facebook,
Wells Fargo,
a Equifax,
you know the scandal around,
um,
around Volkswagen sports.
You got guys that had brain injuries but
the league is and helping them and
they're living in a car.
Their families are destitute or
Hollywood need to say anything.
They're a,
you look across the board and we're
seeing an erosion of what we really
want.
Right?
So there is a tendency,
this man maintains that.
I'm fascinated to read this book,
that we now start looking to politics to
solve these problems.
In other words,
we look at politicians or government to
use in a sense,
coercion,
to restore things to the right balance
and it just doesn't work that way.
Really in practicality.
Now I'm the governor of the state.
Seventh largest state.
I have a,
it's a very powerful executive position,
but I can't just give edicts from up
here and expect it to work.
The people have to be engaged and ascent
and do things.
They have to self govern,
they have to lift.
And so this is a very,
very.
I think this is like the next thing to
think about.
To me it's the next wave.
You know what,
I love what I think it has been fun
because of my friends and because of the
my mind in a way it works.
I'm kind of always looking for the next
thing and I can kind of sense the next
thing,
you know,
and I believe this is something that
really needs to be talked about.
I mean,
it's a virtue.
It's religion,
it's doing well by doing good.
It's driving ourselves from the bottom
up.
It's not trying to vest all this power
in a handful of people in the government
because I think it's futile.
Yeah.
I hate to tell you this,
but in a weird way,
you don't sound like a politician,
but I think you can take that as a
column.
No,
I'm,
look,
I'm a public official.
I'm a CEO of a state.
I'm sick of politics.
Drives me crazy because I see that in
the middle of trying to do things.
Um,
we're all week,
we're all everybody's week and we're all
susceptible to certain pressures,
you know,
and,
and I'm like,
we need to run through that door.
And they're like,
oh no,
no,
no who slowdown here,
you know,
and all that kind of stuff.
And it's,
it's,
here's the problem with politics,
you know,
you could sit next to somebody your
entire lifetime in an office job and
never really know what they think.
But in politics people get called out.
It's really interesting if they get
called out and it's in some ways it's
not fair because it's almost like an x
ray like you know,
you and I could know each other,
we could hang out,
we could watch basketball games and
never ever get into my finding out how
you make decisions in a really tough
situation.
But with politics you're going to have
to vote and if you vote wrong,
you're afraid you're going to lose.
I mean,
it really,
it really is,
is an amazing process and it's
frustrating.
My,
my friend and former guests a couple
times,
Eric Weinstein,
who's a world renowned mathematician and
also and thinker and authors that he
talks about how one of the things we've
lost now is communal sensemaking.
That because everything has become so
politicized,
sports are politicized now.
Hollywood,
as you just mentioned that all of these
things have become so political,
but what does that mean?
I don't know that term.
What does that term?
So for example,
like,
you know,
everything that happened with the
kneeling about the national anthem that
we start that if you turn on sports
center,
you're watching politics.
If you turn on the news and they're
talking about Hollywood,
it's about sex scan,
but politics or is that a discussion of
virtue or values?
Is it politics,
you know?
Well,
I guess at some level it's both,
right on the underlying piece of.
It's a debate about behavior.
It's behavior.
It's not really politics.
No,
I understand what that person would be
saying.
I'm not sure that's the right
characterization.
So yeah,
you're right on espn,
you know,
there's a lot of,
there's a lot of angst over there now
because of different positions.
Uh,
but really kinda debating how we're
supposed to behave,
don't you think?
Yeah.
Well that's what we're doing now.
What was so amazing about the kneeling
it was brought about by the guy that
played for the 40 niners.
People didn't know this.
I was told this,
you know,
he's a devout Christian.
Yeah,
Colin Kaepernick.
When,
when people hear that,
they're like,
Whoa,
you know,
isn't it interesting that when we dig
into somebody who we feel one way or
another about,
it's amazing sometimes how we find out
things that change our fundamental
attitude towards them.
Did you find that that whole situation
actually was what was right about
America in a bizarre way?
I found that everybody was screaming
about,
here's what I.
here's what nobody was staying in jail
and everywhere.
All.
But here's what I think where it got
lost.
I don't feel that the players themselves
were able to articulate to Americans
exactly why they were doing that and
exactly what they wanted,
I think was kind of lost in the motion
as opposed to what is real?
What's behind this?
You know,
what is really behind this,
you know,
I'm a black man and I've worn my kid
that be careful about when you're out
there late at night and what you might
find.
Um,
I think if people heard that and they
understood that,
they would say,
oh,
so that was the one way you had to say
something because it's so divided the
country.
Um,
now,
uh,
you know,
and people had different views.
But you know,
what I found,
Dave,
what I have found in my life is if you
pull people together like we have on
police and community,
tough issue.
I just had two police officers killed,
murdered in my little hometown in Ohio.
You heard about it happened a couple of
weeks ago.
Community needs to understand that mom
and dad need to go home at night.
You know,
they,
they're at risk.
They,
you go to a domestic disturbance and you
have to go in a door.
You are putting your life on the line.
Community needs to understand it,
but police need to understand that if
you are,
that they need understand that
community.
If you're not treating people right in
the community,
you're going to have a problem.
Sit them down the bet,
peel to the better angels.
And in many cases you can come up with
resolutions,
but you have to get the right people in
a room and you have to appeal to the
better angels of them.
Yeah,
I suspect you don't think trump is
appealing to better angels.
That seems to be pretty.
No,
I mean,
I think that,
you know,
look,
my job on this is to my job.
I have a position,
a platform,
I can say things.
I'm not here to be,
you know,
knee jerk against trump.
If he does a good thing,
he shouldn't be praised.
And if he does something that's dividing
us,
then I can't support it to the point
where I didn't even go to the convention
in my state or ever endorsed him.
I wasn't like weaseling around.
I would say that's the wrong word.
I wasn't maneuvering around to say,
okay,
one day I liked him and the next day I
did.
And I just was,
was consistent.
Look,
I took a lot of heat for it.
The amount of pressure that you must
have gotten from the party and from
pressure.
What is pressure pressure?
Whether they say pressures,
uh,
a guy that loses his job,
he's got a couple kids to feed.
That's pressure pressure in politics.
What are they going to do to me?
You know,
what they're going to criticize me,
make you know what we talked.
I mean,
briefly just now about the anthem part.
What,
what are you making the state of race in
America?
If you listen to a lot of people right
now,
it seems like we're at the worst racial
state that we've been.
No,
I think we've made a lot of progress.
I do.
I think though that what we're seeing
now is it's back to this.
I don't want somebody getting something
that I don't get and somebody else took
what I have and why doesn't anybody care
about me?
And I think that caring about me is
real.
Dave,
I do.
Um,
let's say that you,
that you have a kid and you need and you
need a pill to deal with that kid's
problem,
but it's expensive and you can't get it.
Does anybody stand up for you?
You know,
if this is where people feel like,
and this is where community matters,
you know,
they,
if,
if I'm,
if I'm being harassed at work,
how about that story in a New York Times
where these waitresses were being told,
let me grope you and I'll give you a $20
tip.
I mean,
who in that restaurant saw that and
said,
I'm going to take you outside,
right?
To the guy that was the perpetrator.
People tend to feel,
I think too much of the time that we're
in this alone that doesn't that kind of
get back to the overstate this,
but back to the texting and the no
communication.
We got to care about our neighbor.
The way our neighbor cares about us.
We're.
I learned that from my mother.
You know,
tell you interesting story.
My mother and I,
we would hang out at the school all the
time and there's,
the kids came up and gave his pony rides
and my mother wanted to checkout what
does this whole thing going on up there?
So she comes up and I don't have.
It's probably a dime to do a pony ride.
And and my mother was there and she gave
the guy that had the pony a lot more
money than the cost of the pony ride.
And we were walking home and I said,
mom,
you gave that guy a lot of money.
She said,
Johnny,
did you see?
As I was out of place,
we got to help people like that.
Like I used to see my father given a
couple extra bucks to the guy that
picked up the trash because he didn't
make much money.
I'm like,
thanks mom and dad,
because that's something you carry.
All right.
So this is interesting because I feel
like I'm talking to half philosopher,
half governor here.
So let's go.
Let's finish with solutions.
I like that.
By the way,
half philosopher,
half politician,
governor,
you said,
oh governor,
that we go.
That was fun.
But that on your business.
There you go.
You don't have to credit me.
So I want to talk some solutions because
so many things seem wrong in 2016 that I
think that's what led us here.
So we can talk about some of the
specific things.
So like watching the debates that you
were part of,
they're the dumbest way to pick a
president.
Okay.
You can't get from A.
Well you can't pick the way to do it is
now.
Look,
it's all about ratings.
Okay.
So nobody wants to change the format,
but the way it ought to be is what we're
doing.
Let people,
let somebody interview somebody,
find out who they are and then we can
judge instead of like,
who's got the cleverest line or who,
you know,
it's really stupid when you were up
there and trump,
you know,
usually he was brow beating everybody
and you could see sort of each debate
would go by and he'd pick who he had to
go for and,
and you know,
the media kind of fell along with that.
That really wasn't for what you're doing
here is the field narrowed.
He just didn't show up anymore.
He didn't debate anymore.
I mean I wanted them to debate that he,
towards the end when you,
when you stayed to the other guy was
down to fewer and fewer of us.
Yeah.
But I just think it's a bad way to pick
a president now.
We,
I think this all started probably with
Kennedy and Nixon and Nixon lost because
he looked,
he didn't have the right brow,
he was sweating.
I mean,
what a dumb way to pick,
pick a leader.
So,
uh,
I don't know if that'll change.
I don't know because it makes too much
money for the networks.
So what are the things we can do to just
change the electoral system enough?
Like I'm not somebody that believes you
have to go in and wreck everything,
but it seems to me if we could just
tweak something.
Well,
gerrymandering needs to be changed so
that we're not.
Gerrymandering is where you draw
district to favor one party or the other
and then all you have to do is listen to
people and you're extreme and not have
to listen to people who are,
who are different than you,
but you need to be heard.
That's one thing.
Don't have an answer for the finance,
the spending.
I don't know what to do about it,
but I'm open to anything.
So those are a couple of things that
really the issue though,
I mean at the end of the day is it
really,
if we were just to go backwards with
everything,
I think gerrymandering is very,
very serious problem and we are fixing
it in Ohio and I'm proud of my
legislature for doing it.
That's a big part of it,
but it isn't a big part of it.
Also the kind of people we elect,
you know,
and do you carry virtue into these
offices and be willing to take a risk.
I've got a friend of mine now who's just
got on the city council and he called me
the other day.
He said,
I just seem to be making everybody mad
because they all want to have this,
this thing that they want to do and I
just think it's dumb.
And I said,
yeah,
just just,
you know,
pick your battles and be pleasant than
before.
And you know,
we shouldn't want to be in these jobs
forever.
It's natural.
Nobody wants to go to work and lose
their job.
Okay.
Nobody wants to do that,
but you're not in these jobs for,
you know,
for a long time.
I don't think you should be at the end
of the day.
Is that really what the government's
role is?
Just making sure we have jobs.
I mean really,
you know,
making sure we're basically secure.
I think it's the greatest moral purpose
is,
is to provide an environment for job
creation because that's what creates
human dignity,
right?
That's what strengthens communities and
builds a strengthened families.
Uh,
you know,
for the government of the United States
to make sure that we have a,
we are protected,
that we can be free and yet safe.
And then it's also course domestic
tranquility.
You know,
that we're at peace where we are.
So if you have high unemployment,
it's terrible.
So I believe our greatest moral purpose
as politician for me and my job is the
fact that I need to have a job creating
environment.
So it's interesting as I'm listening to
you,
I can understand the reasons for not
liking trump and the tweets and virtue
and all of that.
I can get that in terms of policy of the
things that he's done.
Well,
let's talk about a couple of things.
Let's talk about immigration.
I mean the idea that we're going to ship
these Daca kids out to me as well,
but we're.
I don't even know where the Democrats
are.
We keep talking about trump.
I mean we're in the Democrats.
Is Bart is Bernie and his left wing
philosophy.
Is that where,
I don't know where the Democrats are,
but this Daca thing should be solved.
I mean these are,
these are people,
you know,
25,
26,
27 years old.
It came here when they were six or seven
or eight.
Now we're going to ship them out and
there are a meaningful part of our
culture.
So.
So what do you actually do then?
What they oughta be grandfathered in.
They ought to be said.
You get to stay and then when it comes
to immigration itself,
we need to know who's coming and we need
to be able to protect our borders,
but I don't want to be shrinking legal,
immigration.
I think people create a great deal to
our country,
a trade,
you know,
it's a thorny issue,
but 40 million Americans have trade
related jobs and most of the businesses
that are involved in exporting or small
and medium size businesses and consumers
benefit from open and free enough.
It's not open and free find and have a
process to restore equity but just don't
go out to create a trade war.
Um,
you know,
I mean those are things.
What else you want to ask about?
I mean those are two that jump out at
me.
There's lots of them.
Yeah.
Well I'll throw a couple others that we
actually did meet once before it was at,
I believe it was the first or second
Republican debate and I asked you a
question and you know,
with everyone's jamming the nice,
strong enough where we're jamming their
megaphones in my face.
Trust me,
I had to fight through plenty of people
to get the question.
But basically at my question to you,
was that the social issues that gay
marriage in particular,
I,
I could tell you,
I think at the first debate you
immediately said they asked you about it
and you said that's not what I want to
focus on.
I think,
yeah,
I remember exactly what I said,
but it did get a uh,
you know,
look,
I,
it,
it's not,
I'm not,
that's not where I want to live because
that is a dividing.
I mean,
in terms of gay marriage,
I'm fine with it.
I mean,
I think it was that time when I said I
was going to a,
a wedding of my,
of my gate,
you know,
one of my gay friends who's terrific and
I talked to them all that.
I mean,
I don't even think that way that's
behind,
that's beyond us.
So you'd love for the Republicans to get
past the social stuff,
right?
I mean,
I think in effect the party has even
even the more conservative Christian
side of the party is in talking about
it.
That,
and I got on here Santorum or how could
he really rally taller?
And it's,
you know,
things have changed and um,
I prefer the traditional marriage,
but you know,
I'm not like I don't worry what you're
doing and they're not.
You mentioned to me it's your 21st
anniversary with your wife today.
Exactly.
And I'm here and here you are with me.
What does that say?
I don't know what that says.
Well,
where are you on a medical marijuana or
illegally?
I'm not for legalizing it because it
gets.
I,
I told people when I was in college,
of course I smoke dope.
I mean we,
we all did,
we all did.
But many of us did.
Um,
but here's the problem.
You can't tell kids don't do drugs,
but by the way,
this drugs.
Okay.
So it's a problem.
Medical Marijuana,
we have it in our state and we have it
in our state,
but I don't think legalizing it is a
good thing to do.
Yeah.
Is this one of those things where.
So when I hear that to me,
this is where my libertarian side
kicking him and I would say,
well you can put anything in your body
that you want.
And as long as you're doing it in the
privacy of your own home and the rest of
that's a bad argument.
Makes a lot of sense to me.
But you think that if we just sort of
unfurl this,
that just say I got kids here.
I mean we've got an opiate crisis.
I mean,
you know,
I just was looking last night you got
fentinol and these street drugs,
whether it's coke or,
or heroin and just dropping dead left
and right.
Um,
this is not a time when I think we ought
to be trying to say to kids,
okay,
what?
Don't do any drugs,
but you know,
but this one's okay to do.
That's kind of how I feel about it.
And yet,
you know,
alcoholics,
you know.
No.
And we look and we have a lot of people
die from drunk driving and all that.
But we'd been through that and I don't
know where this is all going to
ultimately end up.
I'm just giving you my sense dealing
with a real problem here.
I don't want to have to explain to young
people the two that you can do this,
but don't do that.
It needs to be a simple message for me.
Yeah.
Okay.
A couple more.
And then the big question at the end.
So,
uh,
I can answer the big question.
Dan.
I don't know what I'm going to do in 20,
20.
I don't know what I'm going to do.
I really don't know.
I am.
I want to be able to participate in a
positive way in the public debate that's
I want my voice to be out there and
that's Kinda what I wanna do and I don't
know where that's gonna take me.
I'm not plotting and scheming,
but I'm making a lot of effort to be
able to have the resources to be able to
stay.
All options are really on the table,
but I don't know what,
what will be exercise because we don't
know what the future's going to bring.
The big question is going to be whether
you want it to play golf with me after
this,
but are you a good golfer?
Not well,
but I not.
Well.
Uh,
okay.
Well,
all right,
that was the answer to that question.
A couple of things.
So you're in California right now.
I know you just met with Arnold
Schwarzenegger and you guys are talking
about how to reset Californian in
politics.
I'm here in California.
It's an insanely high tax state.
If I told you what my property taxes on
this place,
your head would explode.
I should probably move to Ohio if you
want to help her.
All my property taxes are high enough.
It makes my head explode.
Driving in my state.
Trust me in La.
Yeah.
Um,
what,
what do you think can be done to help a
place like California?
That's obviously so less traditional.
It's happening though,
is you're beginning to lose people.
Yeah.
You know,
whether it's to Washington state,
no income tax or to Nevada,
uh,
or to Austin,
Texas.
I mean,
it's,
you don't want to see that happening.
Um,
you've got to make government more
efficient.
And you remember in the old days when
you bought a kindle,
you know,
you had to pay money for it.
Now they'll pay you to have a kid.
No,
I mean we need to use creative and 21st
century technology and techniques to
skinny that government down to get it to
do what it's supposed to do and be
efficient and effective.
You just said you can't believe what it
was like for me to get permission to
build a studio in my garage.
No,
that's nuts.
This is the 21st century.
What are they worried about?
Yeah,
and so,
you know,
I think that,
and I love California.
I mean,
are you kidding me?
I wanted to be out here.
I wanted a campaign out here,
but things move too fast.
I mean,
how could you not love this state,
but you can also do enough things to
begin to drive people in businesses out
in that it's not good.
All right,
well since you answered the big one
already,
I'll,
I'll just give you a,
a wide one to bring us home with,
which would be so many emails that I get
tweets and messages that I get are all
about people that are just afraid to
look.
Can I go back for one second?
Because you were asking about these
social issues.
Okay,
I read an article about Billy Graham who
was,
who spoke to 200 million people across
the globe and he had fights with people
inside of faith because he stayed away
from the hot button social issues of the
time.
I think it is possible.
For example,
I'm dealing with guns right now.
Okay.
And I have brought a group of people
together to mediate that.
I think you can deal with these social
issues,
uh,
by being in a position of bringing
people together at the end.
You may have to walk away from the
table,
but I,
I admire with Billy Graham said,
there's so much negativity in the world
today.
Why don't I like Billy Graham did well,
I don't,
I just focus on the positive things,
the uplifting things.
Instead of dragging yourself down into
these ditches where we just go into
warfare with world war one,
war for trench warfare,
it's not going to help us in the long
run.
Those issues can be dealt with in a way
and,
and on the edges.
But at the end,
let's try to lift our culture.
Casick 20 slash 20 politician.
What was it?
Philosopher slash gov.
I like that.
I see it all coming together.
All right,
so the final one though is that I get
all of these messages and tweets and
emails from people that are afraid to
get involved.
They're just afraid to say what they
think either because of political
correctness or the way it's going to
affect their job or their friends or
anything.
You're obviously out there.
You're.
You're clearly not afraid to say what
you think.
As I said,
there was no preparation.
You sat down and we did this for an
hour.
What would you say to those young people
that want to look?
I mean,
life is short and life is also a
journey.
You got to listen to your conscience and
sometimes it's hard.
Sometimes when you stand up,
sometimes you might lose something,
but in the long run you'll be admired
and leave an indelible impression for
showing courage.
Have people around you that you can talk
these things through because you know
just doing it all yourself leads to self
righteous behavior that is not always
very pretty,
but at the end,
look yourself in the mirror.
Look yourself in the mirror and I happen
to believe that there's a world yet to
come that's really know how am I going
into that one,
Huh?
But there's a world yet to come and I
think our actions here prepare us for
that world and it's going to be okay.
That's how you ended up in interview for
more on Governor Casick checkout,
John Casick.com.